ciara Burgess is a big loser is a 2018
Netflix original film starring Shannon
purser the movie tells the story of a
girl catfishing a guy to like her
without all the eye rolling of Nev and
Max trying to wear as many t-shirts as
possible to prove he's TV's biggest
social justice warrior the film star
Shannon purser wants to make sure that
viewers don't get the wrong idea with
the film's ending and recently discussed
with business insider exactly what the
closing line of dialogue by Jamie means
in the finale
Jamie surprises purses character Ciara
by turning up to the homecoming dance to
take her out in that scene here as the
line honestly had we not met the way we
had maybe I wouldn't have nois to you I
mean you're not exactly everybody's
tired Ciara seems taken aback by yet but
Jamie quickly reassures her that you're
my type you are exactly my type so we
wasn't calling a fat dog down Volare
purse at old business inside of that I
do think that people are going to watch
that and think that he's referencing my
weight which I really hope they don't
that line was in the script before they
had cast me and before they were even
looking for somebody he was with us
sighs which I don't think they really
were initially looking for when they
started casting after the line at Jamie
lifts up that she's smart funny
beautiful and talented and states that
he was impressed by her voice but you
should have also said that she's not fat
Jamie anyway / so close the interview by
saying that I think his comment is in
reference to Sierra's may be creepy
method for getting to know him or also
just to a nerdiness you know she's kind
of an odd egg but I think she has a good
heart
and a lot of remorse for her actions and
he just wanted her to know that he
forgave her for that
personally I think it's great that purse
are created up as I did take it to be
quite a big put-down about their way and
it's great that the filmmakers hearts
were in the right place so what did you
think of Sierra Burgess as a big loser
how did you take the final line and do
you think the way that Sierra went about
getting Jaime was right
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the ending of the nun so make
sure you check that video out next
linked at the end of this one again
thanks for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]